who what is
that him in his
house we're at onth Street what's the
address I don't know you don't know no
sir how'd you get over here you walked
yeah okay this is a long time ago is
what he saying I'm just try to cover me
up you try to cover it up yeah okay I'm
tired to living with my life sir the
guilt hell
yeah
okay
this you doing okay
you're all sweaty did you run here or no
I drink oh you drank oh that water right
there no
okay all
righty yeah go ahead would you show me
where it's at what if I took you would
you be willing to show me where it's at
do I have to go there right now well
that way we know where the the house is
okay I'll let you finish your your thing
let's go
okay you don't want to finish it you're
good there yeah fucked anyways all right
just hang on okay all right
relax relax relax
no name call
911 I did you did yeah we already
goty no just hang out right here
okay let talk about this guy hang out
right here so he's
saying yeah he's saying he uh killed
somebody a long while ago and he bu the
house some House of History that's what
he like
so I asked him he's will to show me
where the house is he's like yeah I'm
going to show you where the house is so
that's that's all we got right now he
doesn't know the address a long time ago
that's it nothing current nothing
current so um I'm going to take him up
there see if see if you want to show me
the house and
then what year huh what year I haven't
figured out yet I lit just was hearing
conversation stuff so what year was this
at you know don't remember okay it's
been so long it's been a long time okay
we're going to go all the way around
over here okay my car is way over there
so we're going to Walk This Way y thank
you guys com
absolutely thank you yeah once I get
your name or once I get you in the car
I'm going to get your name and stuff
okay
we're go to the passenger side here
okay is it on East Fifth or West Fifth
east fth east side
okay just hang out that tire
okay do you have anything on your person
besides your switchers come mind if I
check you I don't
okay
the phone okay I'm just going to hold on
to these
okay have see for me
brother will you give that stuff back to
uh that guy no uh they belong to my
sister she lives right there down the
street okay I left the house okay all
right we'll address it have a seat
okay I'm going roll the window down for
you so here's where we're going do okay
I'm un unff you from here okay and then
I'm going to put them in the front Okay
and then I'm going to let you carry your
water and we're going to take to
detectives cuz they're going to talk two
more okay all right
cool I don't that shit oh I do now we're
going to do in the front Okay cool yep
like that yep all right thank you that
way I'll let you let you be able to hold
your
water okay hey bless yourself man
absolutely Jesus Christ you want to grab
grab your water right here hey or all I
did for everything was
nothing
okay highspeed chases we got unruly
suspects I will kill that mother me no
do it stay in the blue box I like K
dramatic DUI I'mma pass everything that
she trying to do and shocking body cam
footage hey get on the ground get on the
ground law and crime presents body cam
the place for real raw and wild police
videos you should have seen it it was
good it's on body camera I'll show it to
you catch the action and subscribe to
our new YouTube channel
[Music]
now what's your
name I don't want to speak you don't
want to speak okay I told you my name
what you ask me I'm just trying to start
a conversation man okay my name is Tony
Tony prot yeah I didn't mean to back
with any I'm sorry I've been drinking
you've been drinking yeah okay it's my
understanding you called us is that crip
hell yeah you want those off
yeah
so you called us but it's kind of mixed
messages you have handcuffs in K
somebody J and I buried him okay
um got here are you
making do do you feel like you're able
to leave if you if you wanted or do you
want to be here hell yeah I confess to a
murderer okay how how much have you
haded a drink today a lot a lot
yeah well when you find his fucking body
do you it'll make feel better Z's house
that'll make you feel better hell yeah
okay I don't want to live with this
shame anymore okay I understand that all
right well um understand you're you're
willing to Jes yeah it's my
understanding you're willing to take us
to the house yeah oh yeah did it happen
at the house it did it did I was I was
on meth really bad okay and I killed him
because he didn't give me
and I buried him in his house in his
house do you remember his name his name
was Bill name is Bill everybody talks
about it all the time okay how long AG
go I don't
know you don't know too long too long
don't ever say don't kill nobody that
you don't have
to okay
okay
all right Tony well tell you what give
me a sec we're going to go go for a car
ride you want to do that to to his house
or
yeah yeah let's go okay now before we
before we do this you
understand if youone we do find his body
you better find his body it should be
right there okay hey I'm confessed man
mhm I confess I don't want to live live
life anymore without confess
okay just for good measure like you said
you brought you got brought here in
handcuffs I know I know you called us I
know you want to do this because it's
it's a strain on yourself but I just
want to make it clear
that I'm not going to be that person
yeah I I mean I want to make this
perfectly clear that you're telling us
it's it's good on you for doing it but
it it'd be my job I would have to
prosecute this when I discover this you
understand that right yeah so I'm I'm
I'm going to go ahead and advise your
rights just because it's kind of the
state I don't you don't have to tell me
my rights I know I'm fucked I don't even
care if I go to jail for fucking forever
or get the de Deb penalty I should have
never sand and that's it oh man I got
you but just just let me get through
this it's something that's it's
something on my end that they want me to
do okay so okay you have the right to
remain silent anything you say can it
will be can and will be used against you
in the court of law you have the right
to an attorney had to have the attorney
present before any questioning in during
any questioning if you can't afford to
hire an attorney one will be provided
for you and no cost to you and if you
choose to answer any questions or make
any statements you're free to step it up
at anytime okay you understand all that
yeah okay I know you said he drank a
little bit hey I wanted to confess right
I understand all right cool all right so
we're going to go get in a car we'll
drive you to it you show me I'm hot
though will he turn on the air
conditioner it's so hot in here we're
going to go downstairs we're going get
in a car and I'm going to turn that AC
up I hate it up here all right well
let's go cuz we fued anyway okay give me
one minute we get the offic okay all
right you don't need to put the Tony
yeah here's the deal
brother we need some more details all
right what are you to be able to prove
it okay so let's start at the beginning
okay what year do you think this was I
don't remember how old do you think you
were I don't remember what does the
victim look like or what did the
remember what do you mean you don't
remember I don't remember remember I
just know that I killed him why do you
know that because I know that I killed
him kept it
SEC okay why did you keep it a secret
cuz I didn't get CAU how long you been
keeping a secret for a long time like
how long I don't know like 7 years maybe
yeah you see how all your answers are I
don't
know that's what we're having a hard
time with well I said I did it yeah but
we need a lot more detail than
that in order to get get the full
picture of it right and if this person's
dead in here and has been dead for a
long time they got a family right yeah
yeah so the family probably missing them
okay they probably deserve answers on
what happened right yeah so do you want
to give them that I was high and I
didn't give a part okay what were you
high on meth meth smoke it or shoot it I
shot it shot it how much did you use a
day a lot what are you still using no
sir no that's probably why I'm
confessing so why what was the reason
that you killed him I don't I have a
reason you didn't have a reason so were
you guys
arguing no I just felt stupid one day I
guess you just felt dumb what was he
doing when you killed him being a good
man was he sitting sleeping standing
reading watching TV I don't remember you
don't remember but you killed him in a
tub no that's what you said earlier I
didn't say that earli what' you say I
said I killed him and that was it no you
said in the bathroom and it's tell
how'd you kill him didn't said that
how'd you kill him I said I killed him I
was it no you didn't told me how earlier
well he's right there well we're got to
go see if he's in there could but how'd
you kill him I killed him how did you
shoot him no did you hit him with a bat
I killed him how' you kill him I don't
remember did you stab him I don't
remember you did earlier I did
earlier you're just the things that I'm
saying now you see how I don't believe
you if I just came to you and I just
said it all the time I don't know I
don't remember would you believe
anything I'm
saying he said Hey sir what's the law on
this and said I don't know you think you
trust
me that's why I'm having a hard time
trusting you I know I said a guil person
somebody else yeah we're going to go try
and find him okay but I don't have the
details on where he's at
I told you where he was at where's he at
inside the house I don't know
huh where's where's you
burying on the side house right there
okay where the
park the part right there yeah yeah but
what part of that room the left side the
left side yeah if you dig in if you pull
the board up and dig them up okay on on
the left side of the building yeah so
that's towards the courthouse yes okay
which way is his head poined I don't
know which way are his feet poined I
don't know how is he laying in there
he's just dead I how deep is he buried
not very far not very far nope are we
talking like inches yep or like feet
inches inches yep you'll find him you
think he's decayed hell yeah how long do
you think it's been too damn long too
damn long yes
sir what was he wearing I don't know I
don't remember was he wearing clothes
yes or did you bury him naked I buried
him with clothes with clothes you have
shoes on I don't remember did he wear
glasses I don't remember what what type
of person was he white was he Hispanic
uh I think he was
white I don't know you don't know what
he was m and you don't know his last
name no sir how old do you think he was
uh old like how
old I don't know like if you had to
guess how old are
you uh
37 is he older than you yeah how old
your
parents my parents are dead how old
would they be I don't know you don't
know I don't over 50 I don't know
anything okay are you under the
influence of anything right now yeah I'm
drinking alcohol you've been drinking
yeah you want to wait and talk to us
once you're sober uh yeah can you take
me to the police station or what no
we're going to leave you here for right
now what do you mean cuz we got to do
this so you're going to stay here okay
if we find something then obviously we
have more more to talk about all right
cool but we need details to start
working on this so if you can I already
gave you every single detail right but
there's a lot of I don't know so I'm
saying if you start to remember those
things let somebody know all right okay
first thing okay okay otherwise you're
going to stay here for a little while
okay okay and if this is a lie you're
going to be charged with false reporting
okay okay
[Applause]
okay you like on
I got them with outz I hate onions I
didn't I know how some people are you
either hate them or you love
them have you been here for a little
while at the police department mhm my
name is Gino by the way they they just
called me in you you too
sir is that good is it hamburger good
it's McDonald's right is what it is
right so they um they already read you
your mirander rights you're aware of all
that stuff I'm going to I'm going to let
you know again okay it's something that
we just have to do but um you have the
right to remain silent anything you say
can abuse against you in the court of
law you have the right to talk to a
lawyer and have her her present him or
her present with you before during
questioning and if you cannot afford to
hire one will be pointed repr no expense
all right do you understand all that
okay what time did you call the police
department yeah yeah okay tell me what
happened man I killed somebody a long
time ago okay by what
happened I don't know
sir i' I've been told his name is
Bill uh but it's really William right I
don't know you were living with him at
the
time
okay back
then
um you guys had some kind of issue was
it about a
wallet no
do you remember what what happened why
why I just remember I just needed to
confess that was
it okay how did you do
it do you not remember or you just don't
want to say it I just don't want to talk
anymore
okay
well it's off your shoulders now
man thank you for the you're welcome
you're welcome no
problem you know I wasn't I wasn't
around back then
so you know my own curiosity
is you know I I want to I want to
know you know I can read the reports
from from back then and that's why I
said the wallet thing cuz that's what we
were told I know he was an older guy I
know that you were living with him right
you guys were roommates he owned the
place right I don't know but he would he
allowed you to stay there like you were
kind of renting did you pay him money to
live there or I don't he just okay but
you guys were living together all
right so what happened
man
I don't
know do I look familiar to you uhhuh no
you look real familiar to me I feel like
we
talk maybe I've just seen you around
town did you use a
gun I don't
want okay well how about
this why don't why don't you tell me why
you decided to come
forward because my heart
hurts okay he's been eating at you for a
while fuck
yeah
okay I know this is probably
the a a big hard decision you had to
make you been thinking about it for a
while every
day
I've never been in that position but I
can imagine how hard that decision was
to to step up
and at least nobody doesn't have to
worry
anymore yeah I mean I can imagine his
family you know he he was an older guy
but you know his
family never knew what
happened and that's kind of
that's kind of where I stand because I
want to be able
to to tell them you know what
happened tell them that he was a good
man and I should have did what I
did you know okay yeah it it was his son
is the one that reported it to us back
then about not being able to get a hold
of his dad why didn't anybody say
anything after that why didn't everybody
just let him fucking
slide what do you mean I don't know
okay the cops talk to you back then I'm
assume mhm
yeah give me little details Tony what
happened do I have to speak or what no
you don't have to man I'm just talking
to you you don't have to tell me
anything you
don't you don't I just I just want to
know the story I'm sure the family wants
to know the story you know things he was
he was always good to me and I took his
life for no
reason and I don't have an
excuse what did you a lot of people have
an excuse I don't have
one what did you use to kill him I don't
remember do you remember if it was some
type of weapon or your hands I don't
remember all I know is that buried him
and I
shouldn't one of the officers told me
that you had said it was some type of
sharp object maybe like a knife or a
screwdriver or something I
remember okay and again you you don't
have to talk to me but please don't lie
cuz there's no reason to lie anymore
right I killed him with this screw Tri
okay and is that screwdriver around
anywhere no okay cuz it's been I mean I
know it's been a long time yeah
you got family in town here
yeah that's why he wanted to confess for
they don't you know nothing happens to
him it was my fault for my S you
know nobody else should suffer except
this your parents still around no
no
okay so no
reason
all
right so I kind of went back there and
looked at it in the area there's some
crossmembers on the
floor were those there when when you put
them in there no okay so it was just an
open space at the time I don't remember
you don't remember it was in what like
crossmembers you know like if you were
to pull up the floor there's like joyes
like braces uhhuh you know what I'm
talking about like deco diagonal that
the floor sits on no those weren't there
I don't okay did did you have to let me
say this did you have to dismember his
body to get him in there or did you just
put him in their hole I don't
remember was a long time
ago fued anyways I already confessed man
no well see I'm I want I I need to know
this information because I'm going to go
and dig them up all right
and no no no that we we went over there
and looked at it we haven't even got
started yet that's that's a are they
going to take me to jail it's a process
I don't know man I don't know we have to
talk to the district attorney's office
so I'm be stuck here all night or what
no not all night no no but we got to
talk to the Das there're they're the
ones that ultimately make the
decision but those cross members you
know
like there's no there would be no way to
put him in the ground
without dismembering him that that's my
just my curiosity is what I'm
facing all
right is there anything that that you
think I should know that you want to
tell me before I take off everybody
knows everything all
right okay right I'll come back in a
little bit Tony and let you know what's
going to happen okay okay all right I
hope these were decent yeah thank you
you're
welcome